richard good to see you how are you hi
good how are you guys
i'm doing very well listen you're
talking to a lot of people that are big
fans of the mcu that are interviewing
you and
i gotta say it's one thing to be really
suitable for a role and another thing
for
fans to really want you to be in it what
you know the reaction to you having
playing classic loki has been immense
were you expecting this
to be honest absolutely not because it's
a very curious thing when you
are parachuted in to do one episode of
something that
has been established for over a decade
with tom hiddleston playing the part
brilliantly and then
they'd already shot four episodes of it
so when you come in as an outsider
um tom did say to me uh
when when this comes out he said
i think people will there will be a big
reaction to this
and i didn't really believe him um i
thought yeah yeah
it's it's it's uh sounded almost like
publicity speak when people say you know
this is gonna change your life this is
gonna be so big it's gonna
do this and do that but uh
i i have been astonished by i mean just
going by the reviews
and certainly the numbers that have
increased on my
twitter and instagram accounts um and
the response to things and
you know over i think over half a
million people
which is unprecedented in my experience
have watched that little video that i
posted of
myself and owen wilson um my daughter
said to me i think you should post that
dad and i said
nobody'll be interested in this she said
believe me just try
and we just saw the numbers just rocket
so fast
so that that has really astonished me
it really has so tom hiddleston was
right as in all things
yes given that it was
it wasn't an expected thing for you what
was it for you that said okay well
yeah i'll i'll come on and i'll do this
couple days or however many however long
it took you to shoot this
uh i think it was 10 shooting days and
it was
because i've so long admired tom and i
saw him first in the theater
in a production of othello playing
cassio the domain warehouse
with uh chewata etiofour and euro
mcgregor yeah
15 or so years ago i'd so assiduously
followed his career because he's so
talented um and then i
got to know a bit socially and we'd
always joked about working together
because
of our hairlines similar and our body
shape's not that descending of the evs
muscles
and then we play father and son and
something so when this
came about i thought ah finally this is
this is the chance that i finally get to
work with him except that this time i'm
playing an older version
of his character so it was i suppose my
my worry was that i wouldn't be able to
do it justice
and um so i'm relieved that the response
has been
so positive as far as i can tell
you know as someone who's been such a
long time fan like reading the comics
for such a long time
yeah the moment that we first see you in
costume is
actually very very special and you know
what was it like to be on set actually
wearing because it's
it's a very particular sort of suit it's
an old-fashioned sort of
you know super villain costume
right when you were in it what was your
thought
the first time you saw yourself in it my
thought was why don't have any muscles
because the costume drawing that i had
from costume designer and all the jack
kirby draw
illustrations comics this guy had
muscles
proper muscles like you know superman
muscles and so when i got this and i
thought finally i'm going to step into a
muscle suit
without having to sort of eat weight
gain powder and go to the gym for the
next 75 years
and they said no no no i said well how
can i fight asgard if i haven't got
the muscles on this stuff and they said
no that's your magical power and i said
yeah but it would help me if i had the
muscles but they they
it fell on deaf ears so i did feel very
vulnerable um standing there without a
muscle suit
on the first day but i got used to it
that's awesome finally richard you
i think across the board everyone loved
you in this could you see yourself doing
it again could you see any like no one
ever really dies in the mcu
if there was an opportunity would you
come back of course i would in a in a
heartbeat i'd love to
right on that's awesome great talking to
you sir thank you so much
okay